immensité et horizontalité deux termes
qui caractérise bien le paysage
beaucerons
dans ce paysage dénudé ou la monoculture
a effacé le relief tout élément même de
quelques mètres de haut se détache
vivement
un bourrin château d'eau deviennent des
repères dans le paysage chilpéric est
architecte créateur de l'école du
paysage de blois
il aime à comprendre l'évolution du
paysage le paysage c'est de
l'agriculture cdc également des
autoroutes ce sont des ponts ce sont des
voies ferrées ce sont des maisons ce
sont des hangars tous à intégrer à ce
qu'on vient de dire avant forme paysage
la bosse dans notre imaginaire collectif
ressemble à un océan de terres agricoles
avec quelques villages posés comme des
îlots la réalité c'est aussi un paysage
agro-industriel aux lignes verticales
moi ce que je vois aussi ce sont les
réseaux les réseaux électriques les
réseaux téléphoniques les les voilà la
voie ferrée l'autoroute au loin les
chemins vicinaux juste devant nous en
premier plan il ya eu toujours toujours
des événements d'activités humaines qui
ont un moment donné frappé et qui ont
modifié le paysage
l'introduction des éoliennes vient
accentuer encore un peu plus la notion
de verticalité jusqu alors seuls les
cathédrales dépassaient les 100 mètres
de hauteur avec leurs 150 m langis
lignes épurées les éoliennes s'imposent
comme des signes de modernité de
technologie dans un monde oublié
l'agriculture on n'est pas loin de la
cathédrale de chartres ici pas très loin
et bien la cathédrale de chartres quand
on l'a quand on a commencé à la
construire c'était un événement
technologique extraordinaire maintenant
ça apparaît comme que comme une chose
classique à préserver le paysage
au fond il sait en encore caractérisée
avant on le voyait moi je l' ai vu il ya
une trentaine d'années une vingtaine
d'années comme une bosse très cultivé
évidemment très plate évidemment et puis
sont arrivées ces éoliennes
qu'ils ont un qu'ils ont structuré d'une
certaine façon
alors ça grèce peut-être les gens mais
ça veut dire également de l'activité
humaine et ça c'est important mais ce
n'est pas nouveau du tout ça existait
aussi au siècle dernier s agressif et ce
beau s l'est et si cela était une
question de temps et de culture au 19e
siècle le grenier à blé de la france
comptait 1800 moulin comme il était un
outil est symbole visible de l'activité
agricole
il ne gênait pas il faisait partie
intégrante de la culture locale
l'éolienne demain pourrait peut-être
être considérée si son rôle est mieux
compris j'avais une trentaine d'années
on a commencé vraiment à s'inquiéter sur
l'énergie et puis maintenant on commence
à s'habituer un paysage dans lequel il
ya des espèces de machines et de
panneaux qui qui se charge en théorie
parce qu'on est loin d'être on a pas le
compte 1 pour le moment mais qui se
charge de nous apporter cette énergie
le parc éolien en région centre grandi
rien qu en eure-et-loir 200 éoliennes
marquent le paysage de grenier à blé la
bourse pourrait devenir grenier à
électricité son paysage pourrait encore
être transformé carré hall peut prendre
bien des formes innovantes
alors pour les générations futures c'est
chandelles en mouvement feront partie de
leur culture du paysage